Israeli Prime Minister yelapid is
visiting Berlin and he's being
accompanied by several Holocaust
survivors on this his first trip to
Germany since taking office lapid met
with German Chancellor Olaf Charlottes
and one of the key issues they discussed
at the meeting was the nuclear agreement
with Iran a deal that Germany supports
and that Israel opposes
let's take a listen to some of what the
German Chancellor had to say just
moments ago
ladies and gentlemen the Russian
aggression against Ukraine the Russian
invasion of Ukraine of course also was a
topic of our discussion we agree that
this blatant Bridge of international law
is inacceptable the killing in Ukraine
must stop
Germany Europe and Israel We Stand
shoulder to shoulder with Ukraine in
these difficult times
the impact of Russia's war of aggression
can also be felt with regard to Rising
food and energy prices everywhere
it was very joint effort we are trying
to mitigate the impacts of the war
we will also be very happy to offer it
with that on that with Israel in the
field of air defense where Israel has
the arrow 3 system Aid Top Notch of in
that regard Germany's chancellor is
speaking just a little while ago and
let's get some analysis from DW's Chief
political correspondent Melinda crane
Melinda the disagreements over Iran's
nuclear program were high on prime
minister lapid's agenda did we see any
signs of movement there we saw
um diplomatic statements uh that the two
sides do agree on the central aim that
Iran must never get the bomb never
become a nuclear armed power but a clear
disagreement ongoing disagreement on how
to achieve that goal with Chancellor
Schultz saying very clearly we need an
international agreement to get there
whereas your lapid came to Berlin to
essentially persuade Chancellor Schultz
to convince the other EU members member
states who are in negotiations with Iran
to stop any revitalization of the Iran
agreement the agreement as you know was
signed in 2015 under a the auspices of
uh President Barack Obama at the time
who had also said he believed this is
the only way to limit Iran's nuclear
Ambitions and president Donald Trump
took the U.S out of it since then there
has been uh or since uh Joe Biden took
the presidency there has been an ongoing
effort on the part of the western
signatories to the agreement to try to
get a revitalized agreement going once
again and they thought they were close
to achieving that until four to six
weeks ago when the eu3 as they're called
made new proposals and Chancellor
Schultz said Iran could have agreed to
these but has not given us a signal that
they will and therefore apparently there
is a sense in Brussels and here in
Berlin that the prospects for Success
are receding nonetheless Chancellor
Schultz very clear there that he stays
with the idea that an international
agreement with Iran is the only way to
achieve this end and there everyone must
not get nuclear weapons he was very
clear about that can I ask you about
something quite different when yellow
Pete started speaking he launched into
his words with a very personal statement
saying that he as the Israeli Prime
Minister he is the son of a holocaust
Survivor and of course there are several
Holocaust Survivors with him
um in his his delegation how significant
is that it's very significant and in
fact he said something similar when he
landed in Germany he was meant welcomed
by a German military guard and he said
afterwards this is a victory for all of
us a victory for Germany a victory for
me as a holocaust Survivor and a victory
for our country Israel that we can have
close relations with Germany and
Chancellor Schultz had also of course
paid tribute to this close relationship
in his opening remarks and year lapid
will be going together with survivors of
the Holocaust who have accompanied him
on this trip not only to the Holocaust
Memorial here in the heart of Berlin and
but also out to the van Ze to a
beautiful Lake in Potsdam about 30
minutes from Berlin where Nazi leaders
agreed on the so-called Final Solution
exactly 80 years ago in meeting in a
beautiful Villa on that Lake they
decided on the extermination of the Jews
and clearly that too for him very very
meaningful to be in this country that is
now a close Ally of Israel and uh and
which perpetrated the showa absolutely
twe's Chief political correspondent
Melinda crane thank you for that and
that's analysis